[Music]  i banish thee from salem  forever  [Music]  they were right to fear thee  magic has a way of uniting  happy 16th birthday child  i have a gift from my favorite customers  legend has it it's on the 16th birthday  that a witch gets her power  where did you get that candle we have to  get out of here the witches will be here  any second  the book is alive he woke up  if we intend to live past sunrise we  have to steal their souls  wait can we talk about this  no  we must fly  maniac obsessed with getting revenge on  salem sounds  very bad for salem  we should get some salt why so we taste  better when they eat us  [Music]  [Music]  that's not six feet under  stop i am a good zombie  you